[Music]
are you guys getting Kovac kind of
exhausted where you're just like I'm
ready to [ __ ] already I'm tired no no
not even just the quarantine things it's
like it's hearing about hearing about a
mile over it like this country did this
or this restaurant did that or but yeah
I'm like let me just get sick already
but I don't want to
I think cuz everything that happens I'm
like cool just let me know when I can go
out and I've lost because I'm just like
who is telling us what and now we're
getting the whole thing and just tell me
what to do that's all I was they just
keep telling us and especially in LA
it's like bits and pieces first it was
like oh we're gonna be locked up until
March and then I went from March until I
April and they know it
okay we're trying to slowly release you
quickly but slowly and then we're gonna
do quickly and I'm like what the [ __ ]
are you saying yeah it'll be like you
don't need masks and they're like
actually you guys mean mass everyone
wear a [ __ ] mask please oh now they
came out doing actually max don't help
you don't need it again yeah like dr.
fauci he came on and off people who like
him or not did you find out that he was
a lot of labradoodle breeder did you
know that he was a breeder to internet
found that so he breeds labradoodles yes
so you know the Labradoodle are cute
[ __ ] you internet always wins right and
so does this meme that it was going
around and instead of like why are we
taking medical advice from a Labradoodle
breeder and I thought it was the
funniest [ __ ] in the wall and I looked
it up and he is a breeder of lab but
wait what does that have to do it I can
picturing this doctor telling the whole
[ __ ] nation what to do but then on
his off time he's [ __ ] laughter dude
yes vegan having it and like there's a
funny is great I trust that more than
Mike Tyson coming out to me and then
going back to playing with it kissing
out like a pigeon or something I believe
my passing way more I like Mike Tyson
yeah I don't know if I'll be afraid of
them after that you know I'm tired I'm a
bit more afraid you know I'm tired of
though like have you noticed when you
watch like Hulu or whatever if you have
ads on every ad has to be inspirational
every single ad is about it's not about
us the company making this ad it's about
slow piano rift happening every
back-to-back it's so [ __ ] funny they
all went to the same ad agency and they
all had the same idea you know what it
could be so because of the whole covert
quarantine thing I think us sheltering
in and all that depression and anxiety
rates have skyrocketed really those
companies now are like oh [ __ ] they meet
us because people are about to commit
massive suicide no but don't be like I
don't know what's [ __ ] company State
Farm we've been there for you and we'll
be but yeah isn't there also like so
what we're doing is that good good
neighbor we're giving you your money
back and we're still covering your
policy and you want to pay so that's
just an example like every every storms
coming out being like here we know like
this like basically I miss the dumbass
ads you know come by or sandwiches still
no comedy there's no more comedy anymore
I feel like everyone's I'll give you do
comedy you're insensitive it's a time
for JK news then to go even harder
because people need [ __ ] comedy so you
can forget what's happening right now
yeah alright now that's how about Cove
it no no so I mean I kind of a little
bit ties into this so people are just
getting sick and tired of like living in
this quarantine world it can tire
without being sick
Korona exactly with this coronavirus
going everywhere so a lot of people
actually 1.8 million people to be exact
they have all joined a Facebook group
titled a group where we all pretend to
be ants in an ant colony so they're all
pretending to be ants on st. Croix this
is like the RPG kind of like Facebook
thing like roleplay gaming so it says
fellow ants
I found ice-cream munch with me and then
takes them to the Queen and then
assemble lift to Queen nom slurp those
are some big-ass dude so then like
people are just pretending to be in an
ant colony I would have ate that [ __ ]
looks like watermelon mmm like
watermelon ice cream and like this one
says I am under a rock under tunnel 9 8
2 6 6 C 1 all right oh I cannot get out
so like things like that where they're
just all pretending to be little ends
guys I just found this on ground while
doing my daily duties help me lift so we
can ticket to the Queen and admit that
you stole them
what would you do have you seen how
thick the Queen is no they have grouper
rolls so there's ten take seriously
thing one of them is it's like for
example number four rule number four the
the first letters of the words the Queen
must always be capitalized so the Queen
is hot oh they'll they say no sexually
explicit gross or violent content you
can't have a bottle rain I can't join
this group number five those will be no
an tart key and our key anarchy and then
the other one says number six at names
your aunt name is just your name with
aunt in front of it example aunt Jo
please only refer to each other by their
aunt names I can't do it the another
rule is no human politics we're all just
here to have fun
please keep human politics and human
religion out of the group at this time
we're removing all posts and comments
regarding coab in nineteen can i'd be
like hey i'm not trying to sound racist
but have you seen those red ants that
i'm moving in you should try to join as
well get banned like so quickly yeah so
they say your names already on the list
violent red ants moving into our
neighborhoods now I only beat up the red
out cuz it fit another profile watch out
say watch out they might have : no it's
like when they had the trend of all the
fake Facebook events like along with the
area 51 thing now is part of it right
yeah I know there was one that I was
part of that was supposed to happen that
happened this year which is a throw your
BAE into the bay and you take your bay
to the bay and in the bay
yeah but then because the coal bid then
you pushed it to next year was your bait
out no balls gonna pick her up and throw
her name why does [ __ ] hitch be the one
part of the rule like over the pier like
that no just into the bay a special bay
area where everyone meets because that
day is humid it's the beach the bay is
huge no cuz I picture like your Golden
Gate Bridge or something she's not that
good can you die from diving that
hitting the water because I saw it so
you know when they do the Olympic high
dives right do they know like the right
elevation where it's like did you go a
little bit more the day you die and they
also know the entry point of how to go
in but if you just like belly flop under
like a shark but it's not high up to to
kill yourself huh it's a high enough to
clear be given land wrong maybe you
throw like this you can break your palm
but you can't cuz it's like four stories
you're not convinced landing on concrete
Yoshi broke piates a [ __ ] mouth from
mouth cause he was at the he was a part
of the Waterworld show at Universal
Studios innocence he didn't keep his
mouth closed when he did a jump and so
he pencil dived but then his jaw went up
and it just smashed into his eye became
cool with one of the guys that was I
think one of six people that survived
jumping off the clothing say page I'm
like he's trying to kill himself you
tried killing us all oh but he jumped
and you survived yeah wait so you just
said people can't die but then you are
aware that they're survivors and people
that don't survive I'm saying off of the
Golden Gate Bridge is way higher than
Olympic diving diving oh okay okay see
one of those guys who like became a
motivational speaker after yeah yeah he
was on a long haul interview after the
whole suicide [ __ ] that's a great way to
like you almost die and you talk about
it and you make money just talking about
that one event and for the rest of your
life that's all who you are
that's a great job you never have to
change your story or come up with new
material it's the same thing one's if
you get tired of it like a one-hit
wonder band that's like still going
around but you make people feel so good
you know like you're like oh please al
Green's ain't seen that one song and
then you know the artist wants to do
their own remix cuz they've been doing
the same song for like 20 years I do it
like the radio man that's true I don't
want to hear your [ __ ] new version
yeah i don't know i can't sing along to
those shining on the guitar right now
yeah basic [ __ ] yeah i feel like
everything that we want to talk about is
way better than doing and [ __ ] yeah I'd
rather just do not talk about Co vid and
go [ __ ] off and watch it you mean that's
what you're not in this group I know
there's a lot of other things to watch
that can kind of keep your mind off of
this [ __ ] no I guess this is just like
one fun thing cuz like for example there
there's like this like mom and like
ten-year-old kid that are being
interviewed for this article that is
just like their their little side
bonding project they're just escaping
they don't know what citizens of jamala
is yet that's why if they just trying to
find ways to cope exactly yeah yeah yeah
so and then they were talking about in
this article too like how most people we
tend to gravitate to a role-playing game
to cope like to cope with our boredom or
through this this this entire kovat
situation because when you play a video
game and you're anytime that you are
putting yourself in the narrative of
someone else when you watch a movie for
example or like TV show or any of that
like you technically are kind of playing
a role playing game and you might you
might actually feel like you have more
control to like I have more control in
this ant world than I do in this Colvard
rule cuz I can't go anywhere and it's
fun of me so what's the difference
between that in real life what do you
mean we just explained it yeah no I mean
like you can imagine who the [ __ ] you
are and play a character - yeah but I
could come over and talk [ __ ] to you but
then the world
it really you don't really get to
interact with the world because the
world is just in your head so it can
only go so far but now if you're like
connecting with let's saying the deme or
someone and then they're in that same
world with you it just became that much
more fun you haven't played Animal
Crossing have you well I mean that's
that's I get what Josie because I was a
reason that I never really got into
video games because I was like why do I
get better at Call of Duty if I just
pick up a real gun and learn on a shoe
or why do I get good at the target
I am the simplest I run around play
guitar in real life so it just never I
was like life is a video game so why do
I need to play video games those are all
so different generations to know but I
guess I like video games too I hate I
hate playing sport games because I can
go out and play sports you know there's
only ones I I can't play like I like the
ones that like haul duty it was fun when
I didn't shoot and you could pretend to
be a billionaire even when you're not
dude like like playing playing Animal
Crossing right now has really kept me
sane cuz it's like you have your own
little island right but they have the
sounds as if you're there so I just keep
hearing like the waves crashing and I'm
just there staring at the sunset in the
game even though it's like Sun setting
in real life but I'm like I like it
makes me last time feel like it's like
my little like escape into a beach
because I've just been dying to like
meet the social media yeah they act like
different people or they act like that
I'm so good yep yeah it's horrible haha
it was just a bigger game character yeah
[Music]